Do you want to look inside your Django requests?
How about all of your requests in development and see where they overlap?
If that sounds useful, you should definitely check out Colo.
It's a pretty incredible extension for your editor.
VS Code at the moment, more editors to come.
Most likely we have Wilhelm Klopp on to tell us all about it.
This is Talk Python to Me episode 464 recorded May 9th, 2024.
You're listening to Michael Kennedy on Talk Python to Me.
Live from Portland, Oregon.
And this segment was made with Python.
Welcome to Talk Python to Me, a weekly podcast on Python.
This is your host, Michael Kennedy.
Follow me on Mastodon where I'm @mkennedy and follow the
podcast using @talkpython, both on fosstodon.org.
Keep up with the show and listen to over seven years of past episodes at talkpython.fm.
We've started streaming most of our episodes live on YouTube.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel over at talkpython.fm/youtube to get notified
about upcoming shows and be part of that episode.
This episode is sponsored by Sentry.
Don't let those errors go unnoticed.
Use Sentry.
Get started at talkpython.fm/sentry.
And it's also brought to you by us over at Talk Python Training.
Did you know that we have over 250 hours of Python courses?
Yeah, that's right.
Check them out at talkpython.fm/courses.
Well, welcome to Talk Python to Me.
Hello.
Yeah.
Excited to be here, Michael.
I've been listening to Talk Python like for, I can't even remember how long, but
I'm pretty sure it was before I had a first Python job.
So yeah, a long, long time.
That's amazing.
Well, now you're helping create it.
Yeah, exactly.
We're going to talk about Colo, your Visual Studio Code Django.
I don't even know what to call it.
It's pretty advanced, pretty in-depth extension seems to be not quite enough.
So what any project people are going to really dig that people who Django and
we'll see what the future plans are.
If we could talk you into other, other ones, but for now Django plus.
100%.
Yeah.
Django plus VS Code is going to be super interesting.
When we get to that, of course, you must know the drill.
Tell us a bit about yourself.
Yeah, for sure.
So my name is Will.
I've been using Django since, well, I guess I've been using Python since about
2013, I want to say.
So a little over 10 years and yeah, just kind of like fell in love with it.
Wanted to make websites, started using Django and yeah, I guess never really
looked back.
That was in school back then, but kind of always had a love for like tinkering and
building side projects.
I actually studied, I did a management degree in university, but I really loved
hanging out with all the computer science kids, all the computer science students.
And I think a part of me really wanted to impress them.
So I was always building side projects.
And one of them was actually a Slack app called SimplePol.
And yeah, we were trying to like, you know, organize something in Slack and really
felt like the need for polls.
So built this little side project just like during university.
And then it became really, really popular.
And a few years later it became my full-time job.
So for the past like four years, I've been running SimplePol as a Slack app,
building out the team up to like seven, eight of us.
And I had a great time doing that.
In the middle, I actually worked at GitHub for two years, working on Ruby and Rails.
And that was super fun, like a great company, great people, huge code base.
Learned a lot there.
That was really fun.
But yeah, I left after about two years to work full-time on SimplePol.
So SimplePol had been running as a side project kind of in the background.
And actually it's interesting, like, and in kind of the order of events, thinking
back, Microsoft was, acquired GitHub while I was there.
And then suddenly all of my colleagues started talking about buying boats and
leaving the company.
And I thought, hmm, I don't quite have boat money, but how can I, what's an ace
I might have up my sleeve?
And it was SimplePol, which had got like tons of users, but I never monetized it.
So I set out to monetize it.
And then a year later it was actually bringing in more revenue than my salary
at GitHub.
So I decided, decided to quit.
So that's kind of the SimplePol backstory.
So SimplePol is a Django app, reasonably sized now, a bunch of people working on
it.
And then, yeah, at some point in the journey of building SimplePol, I kind of
started playing around with Kolo.
So Kolo also kind of, just like SimplePol started as a side project, but now not to
make polls in Slack, but instead to improve my own developer experience building
SimplePol.
So kind of built it as an, as my own tool for making Django, working with Django
more fun, give me more insight, give me access to some of the data that I felt
was so close, but that I had to just like manually get in there and print out.
So the reason Kolo started out as supporting just Django and VS Code is because
that's what I was using and it was an internal side project.
And now actually handed over SimplePol to a new CEO.
I'm no longer involved day to day and I'm working full time on Kolo.
Man, congratulations on like multiple levels.
That's awesome.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I want to talk to you a bit about SimplePol for just a minute, but before then you
pointed out like, look, I made this side project and how many hours are you
spending on it a week maybe?
Oh, it was interesting.
So honestly, like, so this would like right at the beginning, like when it, when it
was first started, I, yeah, it's a good time.
It's a good, it's a good question.
The, I always joke that the best thing about my management degree was that I had
a lot of free time to like do build side projects.
Honestly, I think it could have been like 20, 30, 40 hours a week.
Yeah.
That was, yeah, I think, yeah, it definitely varied week to week.
And then later on?
Yeah.
And then while I was working, when I had a full-time job as a software engineer,
yeah, that was a lot tougher.
It was like nights and weekends rarely had energy during the week to work on it.
And then honestly, like, since it was a real project with real users, I ended up
spending a lot of the weekend doing like support, like support stuff.
Yeah, absolutely.
Support.
And like, then you charge and then now you have finance stuff and like legal stuff to
do so that, that wasn't super fun.
Like it really slows down the features and the creation of stuff.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I would say I probably spent fully 50% of my full-time job doing email support, that
kind of stuff, you know, just like there's tons of people taking courses and listen to
the podcast and they'll have questions and thoughts and you know, and it's, it's
awesome, but it also is really tricky.
So the reason I ask is I always find it fascinating.
You'll see like news articles.
I don't know.
They're always click baity or whatever.
This person makes three times their job working 10 hours a week on this other
thing, like you make three times what you make for your job.
What are you doing at your job?
Right.
The ability to say you can make that step where you go from kind of tired at nights,
extra time and squeezing on the weekends to full-time full energy.
Yeah.
If it's already doing well, you know, on like a very thin life support, like then
give it full energy, you know, full time and energy.
It's just, of course it's going to be better.
Right.
It's so interesting.
I actually have a lot of thoughts about this.
Maybe I should write something about this at some point, but yeah, I actually think
running like a bootstrap side project kind of business as you have a job can be really
good because it really forces you to prioritize and build the most important
things.
Yeah.
It's kind of like having kids.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
I need to try that someday.
You'll be real tired.
I tell you, you'll, you'll love to prioritize your time.
Yeah.
I think it really forced you to prioritize.
So I actually sometimes recommend when folks ask me like for advice, like should I quit
my job to go all in or not?
I actually sometimes think there's a lot of nice stability and that comes from, from
having a job.
Plus it's actually really nice to have coworkers.
It's nice to have structure.
Like you actually need to take all of that.
Well, work in a way on yourself.
Like it's, you know, if you have to make your own structure, like if you're building
your own thing and that can actually be a bit tricky.
Like I really struggled with that at the beginning.
So I think there's something to be said for, yeah.
For, for spending like a limited time on something basically and prioritizing just,
just the most interesting angle.
And I don't necessarily disagree with that.
I know that's interesting.
So for me, it was interesting, like in terms of like how much, like, you know, life
support energy you put in versus like full time energy.
It was growing decently.
Like while I was still at GitHub and I thought, okay, I'm going to go in on this
full time.
And if I go from like 10 hours a week or less to like 40 hours a week, that would
probably Forex the growth rate as well.
That's how it works.
Right.
And like, totally didn't like it totally didn't work.
In fact, like the month after I left, I had like my first down month where like the
revenue decreased.
And I was like, wait a minute, what's going on here?
How that doesn't make any sense.
That's not fair.
So I think that also points that like there, yeah, you can definitely spend more hours
on something and it can be like the wrong things or not doubling down on something
that's really working.
So, but overall, obviously you, at some point, like just being able to like test out
more ideas is like really valuable.
And for that, like, if you only have time to do support on your product, that's really
working well.
And your full time job is the rest of the, how you spend your week, then yeah, it feels
like you should give yourself some time to build features and maybe quit the job.
Yeah.
It's also an interesting point about the structure because not everyone is going to
get up at eight o'clock, sit at their desk and, and they're going to be like, you know,
I kind of could just do whatever.
And it's, it's a, it's its own discipline, its own learned skill.
A hundred percent.
Yeah.
I remember like one of the first weeks after I was full time on SimplePool, I woke up in
the morning and said, well, the money's coming in.
I don't need to work.
I don't have a boss.
And I just sit in bed and watch YouTube videos all day.
And then I just felt miserable at the end of the day.
Like the, I was like, this is supposed to feel great.
Why all this freedom I've wanted and dreamt about for so long?
Where like, why does it not feel great?
Yeah.
Also, also feels like risk and more different kinds of responsibility.
All right.
So SimplePool, the reason I said it'd be worth talking about a little bit is, you know,
Slack's a popular platform and this is based on Django, right?
So SimplePool is a full on Django app.
Yeah.
And it's funny.
Sometimes people joke that, I don't know if you've gone through the official Django
tutorial, but in there you actually make a polls app in the browser.
Sometimes people joke, wait, did you just turn this into like a Slack app?
And then you productize it.
The getting started tutorial.
Yeah, exactly.
But yeah, like it turned out that like polls and then yeah, getting, you know, your team
more connected and Slack and more engaged are like things people really care about.
So it came to the Slack, SimplePool joined the Slack platform like at the perfect time
and has just been growing super well since then.
Tell people a little bit about what it takes technically to make a Slack app.
I mean, Slack is not built in Python as far as I know.
And it's, it's probably JavaScript and Electron, mostly the people interact with.
Right.
So what is the deal here?
It's actually super interesting.
So the way you build like a Slack app, it's actually all backend based.
So when a user interacts in Slack, Slack sends your app, your backend, like a JSON
payload saying like this user clicked this button, and then you can just send a JSON
payload back saying, all right, now show this message.
Now show this modal.
And they have their own JSON based block kit framework where you can render different
types of content.
So you don't actually have to think about JavaScript or react or any of their stack at
all.
It's basically all sending JSON payloads around and calling various parts of the Slack
API.
So you can build a Slack app in your favorite language, any kind of exotic language if you
want it to.
But yeah, I love Python.
So I decided to build it in Python and Django.
So yeah, actually building Slack apps is a really like pleasant experience.
What's the deployment backend story look like?
Is it a pass sort of thing?
Serverless?
VMs?
At the time it was Heroku.
Simplify was running on Heroku.
And then I think a few years ago we migrated it to AWS.
So now it's running on AWS and ECS.
Nice.
Okay.
So Docker for the win.
Right on.
How does it work in Talk Python?
I'm curious.
How, what's, where are you deployed?
It's all DigitalOcean.
And then I have one big like eight CPU server running, I think, 16 different Django apps.
Not Django, sorry, Docker apps.
No, sorry, Docker apps that are all doing like, you know, some of them share a database that's in
Docker and some of them do sort of have their own self-contained pair of like web app and
database and so on.
But it's all Docker on one big server, which is fairly new for me.
And it's glorious.
It's glorious.
That's awesome.
Very cool.
Yeah.
All right.
So again, congrats on this.
Very, very neat.
Let's talk Colo.
Let's do it.
I first came across this, I've come across it independently twice.
Once when the Django chat guys recommended that I talk to you because they're like, Will's doing
cool stuff.
You should definitely talk to him.
Saying a thing for VS Code is super cool.
But also I can't remember, there's somebody on your team whose social media profile I came across
and I saw this and I'm like, oh, this is, this is pretty neat.
I think we even covered it on the Python Bytes podcast.
Oh, no way.
Let's see.
Yeah, sure.
In January we did.
So that's what we talked about a little bit, but this just looks like such a neat thing.
And it's, I encourage people to, who may be interested in this, to visit colo.app because
it's a super visual sort of experience of understanding your code.
Right?
Would you agree?
Yeah.
I mean, a hundred percent.
Funny thought.
I hadn't really thought that a podcast is going to be a hard way to describe the visual beauty
and magic that Colo can bring to your code.
But yeah, a hundred percent.
Yeah.
So Colo like very much started as like the idea of, Hey, like I should be able to see
like how my code actually flows.
I think like all of us, as we build software, as we write our Python code, we have this
kind of like mental model of how all the different functions like fit together.
How like a bit of data ends up from like the beginning, like to the end, like it passes
through maybe a bunch of functions, it passes through a bunch of like classes, a bunch of
loops, all the state gets like modified.
And we have this kind of like mental picture of all of that in our head.
And the kind of very beginning of Colo, the question I asked myself was like, is there
a way we can just like visualize that?
Is there a way we can just actually print that out onto a screen?
So if you go to colo.app, it kind of looks like this funny sun chart with like lots of
kind of a sunny tree chart with lots of nodes, nodes going from the center and like going
off into the distance, which I think is like, yeah, similar to like what folks kind of
might already have in their head about like how the code flows.
Maybe another way to describe it is imagine like you enable a debugger at the
beginning of every function and at the end of every function in your code and you print
out like what was the function name, what were the input arguments, what was the return
value? And then you arrange all of that in a graph that then shows which function called
which other function.
It almost looks like what you get out of profilers.
Right. You know, where you say like, OK, this function took 20 percent, but if you
expand it out, I'll say, well, it really spent 5 percent there, 10 percent there, and
then a bunch of it. And you kind of traverse that.
A hundred percent.
Yeah. I'm guessing you're not really interested in how long it took, although maybe you
can probably get that out of it.
It's the important is more what is the dependency?
What are the variables being passed and like understanding individual behavior, right?
Or maybe. Yeah.
What do you think? Yeah, a hundred percent.
I think like it's interesting because Colo actually uses under the hood like a bunch of
the Python profiling APIs and people often think of Colo as a profiler.
We do actually have a traditional profiling based chart which puts the timing at the
center. But you're absolutely right that the focus of our like main chart, the one that
we're both looking at that has like this idea of the function overview and like which
function calls which the idea there is like absolutely the hierarchy and seeing like
giving yourself that same mental model that someone who's worked on a code base for
three months has in their head immediately like yourself by just looking at it.
This portion of Talk Python To Me is brought to you by Sentry.
Code breaks. It's a fact of life.
With Sentry, you can fix it faster.
As I've told you all before, we use Sentry on many of our apps and APIs here at
Talk Python. I recently used Sentry to help me track down one of the weirdest bugs I've
run into in a long time.
Here's what happened. When signing up for our mailing list, it would crash under a
non-common execution pass like situations where someone was already subscribed or
entered an invalid email address or something like this.
The bizarre part was that our logging of that unusual condition itself was crashing.
How is it possible for her log to crash?
It's basically a glorified print statement.
Well, Sentry to the rescue.
I'm looking at the crash report right now, and I see way more information than you'd
expect to find in any log statement.
And because it's production, debuggers are out of the question.
I see the traceback, of course, but also the browser version, client OS, server OS,
server OS version, whether it's production or Q&A, the email and name of the person
signing up. That's the person who actually experienced the crash.
Dictionaries of data on the call stack and so much more.
What was the problem?
I initialized the logger with the string info for the level rather than the
enumeration dot info, which was an integer based enum.
So the logging statement would crash saying that I could not use less than or equal to
between strings and ints.
Crazy town.
But with Sentry, I captured it, fixed it, and I even helped the user who experienced
that crash.
Don't fly blind.
Fix code faster with Sentry.
Create your Sentry account now at talkpython.fm/sentry.
And if you sign up with the code TALKPYTHON, all capital, no spaces, it's good for two
free months of Sentry's business plan, which will give you up to 20 times as many
monthly events as well as other features.
Usually in the way these charts turn out, you can notice that there's like points of
interest. Like there's one function that has a lot of children.
So that clearly is coordinating like a bunch of the work where you can see kind of
similarities in the structure of some of the sub trees.
So, you know, OK, maybe that's like a loop and it's the same thing happening a couple
times. So you can essentially I get this overview and then it's fully interactive and
you can dive in to like what exactly is happening.
Yeah. Is it interactive?
So I can like click on these pieces and it'll pull them up.
We actually and this is what's it'll be live by the time this podcast goes live.
We actually have a playground in the browser.
This is also super fun.
We can talk about this. Well, let me drop you a link real quick.
This will be a play.colo.app.
So with this, yeah, this is super fun because this is fully Python just running in the
browser using Pyodide and like WebAssembly.
Nice. OK.
But yeah, so this is the fully visual version where you can.
Yeah. It defaults to loading like a simple Fibonacci algorithm.
Yeah. And you can see like what the visualization of Fibonacci looks like.
And you can actually edit the code and see how it changes with your edits and all of
that. We have a couple other examples.
Wow. The pandas one and the whack-a-mole one are pretty intense.
They're pretty wild pictures.
They look like sort of Japanese fans or whatever.
You know, those little gamer ones.
We once had a competition at a conference to see who could make like the most fun
looking algorithm and then visualize it with Colo.
But yeah, like it's fun.
Like visualizing code is really great.
That's awesome. So this is super cool.
It's just just all from scratch.
It's besides Pyodide here.
Not like VS Code in the browser or anything like that.
I think it's using Monaco in this case or CodeMirror.
But otherwise, this is all is this Pyodide and a little bit of React to like pull kind
of the data together. But yeah, we're really.
Yeah. It's otherwise homemade.
This is kind of like the kind of what Colo has been for like like the past like two
years or so has been this kind of side project for our SimplePool to help like just
visualize and understand code better.
The SimplePool codebase, to be honest, has grown so large that like there's parts of
it that I wrote like five years ago that I don't understand anymore.
And it's like annoying to get back to that and having to spend like a day to
re-familiarize myself with everything.
It's a lot nicer to just like to actually kind of explain like end to end how it
works. You install like in a Django project, you install Colo as a as a middleware.
And then as you just browse and use your Django app and make requests, traces get
saved. So Colo records these traces.
They actually get saved in a local SQLite database.
Then you can view the traces, which includes the visualization, but also like lots of
other data like you can actually see in the version you have there.
Like we show every single function call, like the inputs and outputs for each
function call. So that main idea of Colo is to like really show you everything that
happened in your code.
So in a Django app, that would be like the request, the response, like all the headers,
every single function call, input and output, outbound requests, SQL queries as
well. So really the goal is to show you everything.
You can view these stored traces either through VS Code.
And this is also will be live by the time this episode goes live through like a web
middleware version, which is a bit similar to Django debug toolbar.
Not sure if you've played around much with Django debug.
Yeah, a little bit. Yeah. And those things are actually pretty impressive.
Right. I played out with that one and the pyramid one.
And you can see more than I think you would reasonably expect from just a little thing
on the side of your web app.
Yeah, exactly. And that's very much our goal to like very kind of deep insight in our
minds. This is almost like a bit like old news.
Like we've been using this for like a few years, basically.
And then at some point, like last year, we started playing around with this idea of
like, OK, so we have this trace that has information about like pretty much everything
that happened in like a request.
Is there any way we could use that to solve this like reasonably large pain point for
us, which is like writing tests?
I'm actually curious. Do you enjoy writing tests?
I'll tell you what I used to actually.
I used to really enjoy writing tests.
I used to enjoy thinking a lot about it.
And then as the projects would get bigger, I'm like, you know, this is these tests don't
really cover what I need them to cover anymore.
And they're kind of dragging it down.
And then, you know, the thing that really kind of knocked it out for me is I'd have
like teammates and they wouldn't care about the test at all.
So they would write, break the tests or just write a bunch of code without tests.
And I felt kind of like like a parent cleaning up after kids.
You're like, why is it so?
Can we just pick up? Why are there dishes here?
And they're just going around.
I'm like, this is not what I want to do.
Like, I want to just write software.
And I understand the value of tests, of course.
A hundred percent.
Yeah. At the same time, I feel like maybe higher order integration tests often, for
me at least, serve more value because it's like I could write 20 little unit tests or I
could write two integration tests and it's probably going to work.
I'm actually completely with you on that.
OK, right on.
The bang for the buck of integration tests are like great, like really, really useful.
You can almost think of tests as having like two purposes, one being like, well,
actually, I think this would be too simple an explanation.
Let me let me not make grand claims about all the uses of tests.
I think the most the use of it that most people are after is this idea of like what I've
built isn't going to break by accident.
Yeah. Like you want confidence that any future change you make doesn't impact a bunch
of unrelated stuff that it's not supposed to impact.
I think that's what most people are after with with tests.
And I think for that specific desired result, like integration tests are the way to go.
And there's some cool writing about this from I wrote a little blog post about Colos
test generation abilities.
And in there, I link to a post from Kent C.
Dodds from the JavaScript community, who has a great post about I think it's called
write tests, not too many, mostly integration, kind of after this idea of like, yeah, nice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Eat not too much, mostly vegetables.
I think that's the.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I'm a big fan of that.
And actually, it's interesting.
I've speaking to a bunch of folks over the past year about tests.
A lot of engineers think about writing tests as vegetables.
And obviously, some people love vegetables and some of us love writing tests.
But it seems like for a lot of folks, it's kind of like a obviously necessary part of
creating great software.
But it's maybe not like the most fun part of our job.
Or you pick up some project, you're a consultant, or you're taking over some open
source project, you're like, this has no tests, right?
It's kind of like running a linter.
And it says there's a thousand errors.
You're like, well, we're not going to do that.
Yeah, we're just not going to run the linter against it because it's just too messed up
at this point, right?
It's interesting you mentioned the picking up like a project with no tests, because I
think within the next three months, we're not quite there yet.
But I think in the next three months with Colo's test generation abilities, we'll have
a thing where, yeah, all we need is a Python code base to get started.
And then we can bring that to like a really respectable level of code coverage just by
using Colo.
Okay.
How?
That's kind of describing a second ago how like we, SimplePol has tons of integration
tests.
SimplePol actually is about 80,000 lines of application code, not including migrations
and like config files.
And then it's about 100,000 lines of tests.
And most of that is integration tests.
So SimplePol very well, very well tested lots of really mostly integration tests.
But it is always a bit of a chore to like write them.
So we started thinking about like, hmm, this like Colo tracing we're doing, can that help
us with making tests somehow?
And then we started experimenting with it.
And like to our surprise, it's actually, yeah, I'm still sometimes surprised that it
actually works.
But basically the idea is that if you have a trace that has that captures everything in
the request, you can kind of invert it to build a integration test.
So let me give an example of what that means.
The biggest challenge we found with creating integration tests is actually the test data
setup.
So getting your application into the right shape before you can send a request to it or
before you can call a certain function, that's like kind of the hardest part.
Writing the asserts is almost like easy or even like fun.
Right.
There's the three A's of unit testing range, assert, and act, wait, arrange, act, and
assert.
Exactly.
Yeah.
The first and the third one that you kind of have data on, right?
Exactly.
Yeah.
So we're like, wait a second.
We actually can like kind of extract this, like the act.
So like the setting, sorry, the arrange, setting up the data, the act, like actually
making the HDP request and then the assert, like to ensure the status change or that the
request go to 200 or something.
We actually have the data for this.
It's reasonably straightforward.
Like if you capture in, you know, just your like normal, like imagine you have a local
to do app and you browse like a to do kind of demo, simple to do app and you browse to
the homepage and the homepage maybe lists the to dos.
And if you've got Colo enabled, then Colo will have captured the request, right?
So like the request went to the homepage and it returned a 200.
So that's already like two things we can now turn into code in our integration test.
So first step being, well, I guess this is the act and the assert in the sense that the
assert is the 200 and then the act is firing off a request to the homepage.
Now the tricky bit, and this is where it gets the most fun, is the arrange.
So if we just put those two things into our test and our two imaginary test, there
wouldn't have been any to dos there.
Right.
So it's actually not an interesting test yet, but in your local version where the
trace was recorded, you actually had maybe like three to dos already, already in your
database.
Does that make sense so far?
Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
On the homepage, like your to do app might make a SQL query to like select all the to
dos or all the to dos for the currently logged in user.
And then Colo would store that SQL query, would store that select and would also store
actually what data the database returned.
This is actually something where, yeah, Colo goes beyond a lot of the existing kind of
like debugging tooling that might exist, like actually showing exactly what data the
database returned in a given SQL query.
But imagine we get like a single to do returned, right?
We now know that to replicate this like trace in our test, we need to start by seeding
that to do into the database.
That's where like the trace inversion comes in.
If like a request starts with a select of like the to do table, then the first thing
that needs to happen in the integration test is actually a like creating like an insert
into the database for that to do.
And now when you fire off the request to the homepage, it actually goes through your real
code path where like an actual to do gets loaded and gets printed out onto the page.
So that's like the the most basic kind of example of like, how can you turn like a
locally captured trace of a request that like made a SQL query and return 200 into like
an integration test?
Yeah, that's awesome.
One of the things that makes me want to write fewer unit tests or not write a unit test
in a certain case is I can test given using mocking, given my let's say SQLAlchemy or
Beanie or whatever Django ORM model theoretically matches the database.
I can do some stuff, set some values and check that that's all good.
But in practice, if the if the shape, if the schema in the database doesn't match the
shape of my object, the system freaks out and crashes and says, well, that's not going
to work, right?
There's no way.
And so it doesn't matter how good I mock it out.
It has to go kind of end to end before I feel very good about it.
Oh, yeah.
OK, it's going to really, really work, right?
Exactly.
That's an interesting story.
Like you're saying to like, let's actually see if we can just create the data, but like
let it run all the way through.
Right.
I'm totally with you.
And and I think I've often seen like unit tests pass and say, I mean, there's like lots
of memes about this, right?
How like unit tests say everything is good, but the server is down.
Like, how is that possible?
I think in Django world, it's reasonably common to write integration tests like this, as in
like the actual database gets hit.
The you have this idea of like the Django test client, which sends like a, you know,
real in air quotes, HTTP request through the entire Django stack as opposed to doing the
more unit test approach.
So it hits the routes.
It hits like all of that sort of stuff all the way.
Yeah.
And the template.
And then at the end, you can assert based on like the content of the response or you can
check.
Like, imagine if we go back to the to do example, if we're testing like the add to do
endpoint or form submission, then you could make a database query at the end.
And Kolo actually does this as well, because like, again, we know like that you inserted
to do in your request, so we can actually make an assert.
This is a different example of the trace inversion.
If there's an insert in your request that you captured, then we know at the end of the
integration test, we want to assert that this row now exists in the database.
So you can assert at the very end to say, does this row actually exist in the database
now?
So it's a very nice kind of reasonably end to end, but still integration test.
It's not like a brittle click around in the browser and kind of hope for the best kind of
thing.
It's like, as we said at the beginning, I think like integration tests just get you
great bang for your buck.
They really do.
It's like the 80/20 rule of unit testing for sure.
Yeah.
Talk Python to me is partially supported by our training courses.
If you're a regular listener of the podcast, you surely heard about Talk Python's online
courses, but have you had a chance to try them out?
No matter the level you're looking for, we have a course for you.
Our Python for absolute beginners is like an introduction to Python plus that first
year computer science course that you never took.
Our data-driven web app courses, build a full pypi.org clone along with you right on the
screen.
And we even have a few courses to dip your toe in with.
See what we have to offer at training.talkpython.fm or just click the link in your
podcast player.
So is this all algorithmic?
Yup.
Great question.
Is it LLMs?
Like how much VC funding are you looking for?
Like, you know, like if you got LLMs in there, like coming out of the woodwork.
No, I'm just kidding.
No, how do you, how does this happen?
It's actually all algorithmic and rule-based at the moment.
So this idea of a select becomes like a, like a, an insert and an insert becomes like a
select assert.
We were surprised how far we could get with just rules.
The benefit we have is that we kind of have this like full-sized SimplePol Django code
base to play around with.
And yeah, like generating integration tests in SimplePol just like fully works.
There's a bunch of tweaks we like had to make to, as soon as I guess you work in kind of
like outside of a demo example, you want like time mocking and HTTP mocking and you want
to use your like factory boy factories and maybe you have a custom unit test, like base
class and all of this.
But yeah, it like, it actually works now.
I gave a talk at DjangoCon Europe last year.
It's kind of like a bit of a wow moment in the audience where, yeah, you just click
generate test and it generates you like a hundred line integration test and the test
actually passes.
So that was like, people started, just started clapping, which was a great feeling.
I'm still a bit surprised that it works on it, but yeah, no LLM at all.
I do think like LLMs could probably make these tests like even better.
Or you know how I was saying a second ago, like in three months we could go take a code
base from like zero test coverage to maybe like 60%, 80%.
I imagine if we made use of LLMs that would help make that happen.
Yeah.
You could talk to it about like, well, these things aren't covered.
Right.
What can we do to cover them?
Yeah.
I don't know if you maybe could do fully, fully automated, just push the button and
let it generate it.
But you know, it could also be like a conversational, not a conversation, sort of a
guided, let's get the rest of the test, you know, like, okay, we're down to 80, we've
got 80%, but there's the last bit are a little tricky, like what ones are missing?
All right.
So how do you think we could do this?
Is that about, no, no, you need to, that's not really the kind of data we're going to
pass.
You know, I don't know.
It seems something like that.
Right.
I really liked that.
I had not thought about like a conversation as a way to generate tests, but that makes so
much sense.
Right.
It kind of bring in the developer along with them where it's gotten too hard or something,
you know?
Yeah.
There's something cool about just clicking a button and see how much code coverage you
could get to, but chatting to it.
I think also, honestly, like so far, like our test generation logic is a bit of a black
box.
It just kind of like works until the point where like it doesn't.
So we're actually kind of in the, in the process of like shining a bit more of a light
into like, like essentially the like internal data model that Colo keeps track of to know
what the database state should be like in this arrange part of the integration test.
And yeah, we're actually like in the process of like, yeah.
Talking to a bunch of users who are already using it and also finding like companies who
want to increase their, increase their test coverage or who have problems with their
testing and want to improve that and kind of working closely with them to make that
happen.
That's kind of a huge focus for us as we figure out like, how do we want to monetize
Colo?
Like so far Colo has just been kind of supported by SimplePool as a, as a side project,
but we're kind of making it real, making it its own business.
So, and we think the test generation is going to play a big part in that.
Right.
Like that could be a, certainly a premium team feature sort of thing.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Enterprise.
Enterprise version comes with auto testing.
Yeah, exactly.
Something like that.
Yeah.
If there's anyone listening and like they're keen to increase their code coverage, please
email me.
Maybe we can leave my email in the, in the notes or something like that.
Yeah.
I'll put your contact info in the show notes for sure.
It's actually really nice.
It's just w@colo.app.
Oh, very nice.
So yeah.
If, if anyone's listening and wants to kind of like increase their code coverage or has a
lot of code bases that have zero coverage that would benefit from getting to like some
level of coverage, we'd love to help you and talk to you.
Even if the solution doesn't like involve using Colo, just really, really keen to talk to
anyone about like Python tests and, and what can be done there.
So yeah, please hit me up.
Awesome.
Yeah.
I'll definitely put some details in the show notes for that.
I have some questions as well.
Please.
Yes.
Right here.
I'm looking at the webpage and the, the angle bracket title is Colo for Django.
But in the, the playground thing you sent me, it was on plain Python code.
It was on algorithms.
It was on pandas, which I thought was pretty interesting how much you could see inside
pandas.
Makes me wonder, you know, if you look at the web frameworks, there's two or three more
that are pretty popular out there and they all support middleware.
Yeah.
A hundred percent.
So Colo kind of started as like this, like side project for our Django app.
And I think that that's why we kind of went there first.
It's kind of the, the audience we know best.
You do dog food as well.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Dog fooded Lily.
Who's, who's an engineer on the team is, and who's been building a lot of, yeah, a
lot of the Python side of Colo is like a core contributor to Django.
So Django is like really where we're home.
And to be honest, I think when building a new product, it's kind of nice to keep the
audience somewhat small initially keep like building for very specific needs as
opposed to going like very wide, very early.
That was kind of very much, very much the intention, but there's no reason why Colo
can't support Flask, FastAPI, the scientific Python stack, as you can see in
the playground, it does totally work on, on plain Python.
It's really just a matter of.
Honestly, like FastAPI support would probably be like a 40 line config file in
it, exactly in like our code.
And there's actually, yeah, we're thinking of ways to make that actually a bit more
pluggable as well.
There's only like so many things we can reasonably support.
Well, ourselves.
I was going to say if somebody else out there has an open source project, they want it to
have good support for this, right?
Like, Hey, exactly.
Yeah.
I run HTTPS or I run light star or whatever, and I want mine to look good here too.
Right.
Totally.
So the thing you can do already today is there's a little bit of config you can pass
in.
And actually, if you look back on the pandas example, you'll, you'll see this by
default.
Colo actually doesn't show you library code if you use it in your own code base, but you
can tell it, show me everything that happened, like literally everything.
And then it will, it will do that for you.
So in this example you're looking at, or if anyone's looking at the playground, if you
look at the pandas example, it'll say like include everything in pandas.
And that'll give you like a lot more, a lot more context.
The thinking there is that most people don't really need, like the issues you're going
to be looking at will be in your own code or you're in your own company's code base.
You don't really need to look at the abstractions, but you totally can.
But yeah, to answer the question, like we have this like internal version of a plugin
system where yeah, like anyone could add FastAPI support or like a great insight into
PyTorch or what have you.
The way it all works technically really is it's totally built on top of this Python API
called set profile.
I'm not sure.
Have you used, have you come across this before?
It's a bit similar to set trace actually.
Yeah, I think so.
I think I've done it for some C profile things before.
I'm not totally sure.
Yeah.
It's a really neat API to be honest, because Python calls back to your, like the callback
that you register on every function, enter and exit.
And then Colo essentially looks at all of these functions, enters and exits and decides
which ones are interesting.
So the matter of like supporting say FastAPI is basically just telling Colo these are
the FastAPI functions that are interesting.
This is the FastAPI function for, for like an HTTP request that was served.
This is the HTTP response.
Or similarly for SQL alchemy, this is the function where the query was actually executed
and sent to the database.
This is the variable which has the query result.
Like there's a little bit more to it and I'm definitely like, yeah, generalizing, but
it's kind of like in principle, it's as simple as that.
It's like telling Colo, here's the bits of code in a given library that are interesting.
Now just kind of like display that and make that available for the, for the test generation.
Excellent.
Yeah.
I totally agree with you that it getting focused, it probably gets you some more full
attention from the Django audience and the Django audience is quite a large and
influential group in the Python web space.
So that, that makes it totally, especially since you're using it.
By the way, it was Lily's Mastodon profile, I believe that I ran across that I first
discovered Colo from.
So of all the places, yeah.
Or a, a, a post or something like that.
That's awesome.
Cool.
All right.
So let's talk about a couple other things here.
For people who haven't seen it yet, like you get quite a bit of information.
So if you see like the get request, you actually see the JSON response that that
was returned out of that request and it integrates kind of into your editor
directly, right?
If you've seen code lens before, it's kind of like code lens, right?
Yeah.
This is another thing which I think is, is pretty novel with, with Colo.
Like I think it's reasonably common for existing debugging tools to show you like,
Oh yeah, this is the headers for the request, or this is like the response status
code.
But especially working with the Slack API in simple poll, you're constantly looking
at payloads and what were the values for things and what are you returning.
In production, you don't directly get to even make those or receive those requests,
right?
There's some like system in Slack who was like chatting with your thing.
You're like, well, what is happening here?
Right.
Not that you would actually run this in there, but you know.
I mean, it's funny you mentioned this because there is one experiment we want to
run of kind of actually enabling these extremely deep and detailed Colo traces
in production.
We haven't explored this too much yet, and I think we're going to focus a little bit
more on the test generation, but you could imagine like a user who's using, who's on
the talk Python side and they've, they've got some incredibly niche error that no one
else is, is like encountering and you've tried to reproduce it, but you can't
reproduce it.
Maybe there's a little bit of information in like your logging system, but it's just
not enough.
And you keep adding more logging and you keep adding more logging and it's just not
helping.
Like imagine a world where you can say just for that user, like enable Colo and
enable like these really deep traces.
And then you can see whenever the user next interacts, like the value for every
single variable for every single code path that executed for that user.
That's just like, yeah.
I think one of our users described as like a debugger on steroids.
Yeah.
It's pretty interesting.
Sounds a little bit like, like what you get with Sentry and some of those things,
but maybe also a little bit different.
So, you know, you could do something like, here's a dear user with problem.
Here's a URL.
If you click this, it'll set a cookie in your browser and then all subsequent
behavior, it just hits on it.
You know what I mean?
It's like recording it.
Yeah.
That'd be pretty interesting.
I think it makes sense in the case.
Like if a user, it could even be an automated support thing, right?
Like if a couple of sites have this where you can like do like a debug dump before
you submit your support ticket, this is almost like, like that.
And then as an engineer who's tasked with digging into that user's bug, you don't
have to start with like piecing together.
What was this variable at this time when they made that request three days ago?
You like, you can just see it.
If an error ever encounters an exception on your site, you just set the cookie.
Right.
All everything else they do is now just recorded until you turn it off.
Oh my God.
You're giving me so many good ideas.
That'd be fun.
I'm going to start writing this stuff down.
Let's record it.
It'll be fine.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of stuff that's, that's, that's interesting.
People can check it on the site.
It's, it's all good.
However, we talked a little bit about the production thing.
Like another thing you could do for production, if this requires both a
decent amount of traffic and maybe, maybe you could actually pull this off on just a
single server, but you could do like, let's just run this for 1% of the traffic so that
you don't kill the system, but you get, you know, if that's why I see you have
enough traffic, it's like statistically significant sampling of what people do
without actually recording a million requests a day or something insane.
A hundred percent.
I think there's really something there, or like, I could go on about this whole
idea of like runtime data and like improving software understanding for days.
Because I just think like, it's really this like missing layer, right?
Like all of us constantly imagine like, what is like, we play computer looking at
our code, imagining what the values can be, but like, yeah, say you're looking at
some complex function in production and you want to understand how it works.
Like how useful would it be if you could see like the 10, the last 10 times it was
called, like what, what were the values going into it and what were the values
coming out of it?
Like, that would be, I just think like, why do we not have this already?
Like, why does your editor not show you for every single function in the code base,
give examples of like how it's actually used like in production.
Yeah.
And then use those to generate unit tests.
And if there's an error, use that to generate the edge case, like the negative
case, not the positive case unit test.
Right.
There you go.
Exactly.
It's all like kind of hanging together.
Like, yeah.
Yeah.
Once you have the data, you have interesting options.
Business model.
This is not this, I maybe should have started sooner with this, but it's not
entirely open source that maybe a little, little bits and pieces of it, but in
general, it's not open source.
That's correct.
Yeah.
No, I'm putting that out there as a negative, right?
This looks like a super powerful tool that people can use to write, write code
and that's fine.
Yeah.
I think the open source question is super interesting.
Like it's always been like something we've thought about or, or considered.
I think there is, yeah, with, with developer tools, I think business
models are always super interesting and we want to make sure that we can have a
business model for Colo and like run it as like a sustainable thing, as opposed to
it just being like a simple poll side project kind of indefinitely be great.
If Colo could like support itself and yeah, have a business model, I think that's how
it can like really fulfill its potential in a way, but that's not to say that like
Colo won't ever be open source.
Like I think there's a lot to be said for open sourcing it.
I think especially like the, the capturing of the traces is maybe something like I
could see us open sourcing.
I think the open source community is fantastic.
I do also think it's not like a thing you get for free, right?
Like as soon as you say, Hey, we're open source, you open yourself up to
contributions, right.
And to like the community actually getting involved and that's great, but it also
takes time.
And I think like that's a path I would like to go down when we're a little bit
clearer on like what Colo actually is and like where it's valuable.
If that makes sense.
Yeah, sure.
If it turns out that no one cares about like what, how, like how to visualize code,
then like, that's a great like learning for us to have made, but I'd rather get
there without like a lot of work in the middle that we could have kind of avoided
if that makes sense.
So for sure, it feels like once we have a better sense of the shape of Colo and what
the business model actually looks like, then we can be a bit more, yeah, we can
invest into open source a little bit more.
But to be honest, like based on how everything's looking right now, I would
not be surprised at all.
If like big chunks, it's like Colo becomes open core or big chunks of it are like
open source.
It makes sense to me.
It is fully free at the moment.
So I should, that's worth calling out.
Yeah.
There's no cost or anything.
You can also like, you know, you download the Python package and guess what?
You can look at all of the code.
Like it actually is all of theirs.
It is all kind of visible.
That kind of leads into the next question is I've never used GitHub Copilot and a few
of those other things because it's like here, check this box to allow us to upload
all of your code and maybe your access keys and everything else that's interesting.
So we can one, train our models and two, you know, give you some answers.
And that just always felt a little bit off to me.
What's the story with the data?
At the moment, Colo is like entirely like a local product, right?
So it's all local.
Like you don't have to, you can get like all of the visualization, everything just
by using local Colo in, in VS Code.
We do have a way to like upload traces and share them like with a colleague.
This is actually also something I think is like kind of playing with the idea of like
writing a little like Colo manifesto.
Like what are the things that we believe in?
One of them that I believe in, and this goes back to the whole like runtime layer on top
of code.
And like, there is this whole dimension, this like third dimension to code that we're
all simulating in our heads.
I think like it should totally be possible to not just like link to a snippet of code
like on GitHub, but it should be possible to have a like link, like a URL to a specific
execution of code, like a specific function and actually talk about that.
It's kind of wild to me that we don't have this at the moment.
Like you can't send a link to a colleague saying, Hey, look at this execution.
That looks a bit weird.
We ran this in continuous integration and it crashed, but I understand.
Let's look at the exact.
Right.
The whole deal.
You can link to like CI runs.
You can link to like sentry errors, but like if you're just seeing something slightly weird
locally or like even something slightly like weird in production where there's no area,
you can't really like link, link to that.
Anyway, like this is kind of a roundabout way of me saying that, like, I think that
totally should be a thing.
Like you should be able to link like generically to like a execution of a function or an
execution of a request.
And like that would totally have to live somewhere.
Right.
So this is where there's some idea of like colo cloud comes in and this is where you
could like connect your, your repository.
And then Kolo would like, as part of that, you know, just like get help, does have
access to your code and like show you the code and in like the colo cloud.
So I think there's definitely like useful things that are possible there, but at the
moment it's a fully local experience.
Like your, your code doesn't ever leave your, your system.
You can, if you want to like upload traces and then Kolo stores the like trace data,
not, not the code, just the trace data.
But yeah, very local experience right now.
Yeah.
A little SQLite database.
Exactly.
Yep.
Yeah.
SQLite's pretty awesome.
It's a fightable piece of software.
Yeah, it really, really is.
Let's close out our conversation here with a little bit of a request from Michael.
Right now it's VS Code only.
Any chance for some PyCharm in there?
This is our top request, like PyCharm support.
Yeah.
And we've decided super small team, like we want to kind of support everyone, but
we've been working very heavily actually the past few months on a web-based version,
which is, I'm happy to say like very much nearing completion.
And there's a few bits and pieces where like, it's really nice to be integrated
super deeply into the editor, like the code lenses and, and all of that.
And I think there's a chance we'll have that for PyCharm eventually as well.
But we actually found that like building out this web version, there's a few things
that are actually much nicer when you have the full control over the UI in terms of
like browsing around a trace, highlighting little bits of code.
So for example, in Colo, like a given function call, we call a frame and you
can look at a given frame, both in VS Code, but also in the web version and see the
code and see all of the data that passed through the code.
But something we can do in the web version we can't do in VS Code is actually show
where the current function was called from and actually show like a preview of that
code.
In VS Code, you can't really show like, you can layer multiple files together or
different.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
There's actually a lot of, like, I was surprised by how many different novel,
like kind of ways we had in the web that we just never even considered with like a
direct editor integration in terms of displaying this runtime data.
So like, long story short, like you, you know, want a PyCharm integration.
Let me give you something even better.
Yeah.
Web version.
So would that work like you run a certain command or something when you run your web
app and then it just generates the SQL lite file and then you could just explore it
with a web view or what are you?
Yeah, it's actually kind of cooler than that.
So if you're using Django or in the future, like other things with a typical
middleware, you would just like go to your, you would just go to localhost
8000/hello.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Kind of like you do for open API docs.
Yep.
And then the whole experience is just there.
If you're not using a middleware, we'll have a command like colo serve or something
like that.
And that'll yeah.
Host the same experience for you.
Just make sure it's off by default or it only, it only responds on localhost or
something like that.
You know, like, yeah, exactly.
Don't let people ship it on accident.
That would be bad news.
No production use of this.
Yeah.
I mean, people already know about the Django debug settings, but right.
I guess you could sort of layer onto that, right?
Probably.
Yeah.
I think we actually do that at the moment.
But yeah, it's worth, worth remembering.
No, I just think, you know, like, well, this is really cool.
It makes for a hundred percent.
CNN.com is awesome.
Look what it's doing.
Look at all these requests and all this.
Yeah, exactly.
A hundred percent.
Yeah.
Oh, and the API key is so interesting.
Anyway, that's a bit of a side, a side conversation.
So let's just, let's wrap it up with the final call to action.
People are interested.
What do they do?
Yeah.
Colo.app and check it out.
We have a playground link there.
Play.colo.app.
Easiest way to kind of see what Colo is and what Colo does, but we'll say the
most powerful way to, to actually see Colo in action is to use it on your own
code base.
So seeing the visualization and the test generation capabilities is just like,
yeah, the most useful when you use it on your code base.
So hopefully the playground can entice that a little bit.
And yeah, really the main, most important thing for us right now is, yeah.
Chatting to folks who want to increase their test coverage, want to like build
automated testing as part of their workflow.
And yeah, work very closely with you to make that happen.
So if that's you, please email me at w@colo.app.
You need that pause for the W that's right.
Or the two, the two at's.
Awesome.
Will, thanks for being on the show.
Congrats on both of your projects.
They look really neat.
Thanks so much for having me.
Yeah.
So excited to have been on.
Yeah, you bet.
Bye.
This has been another episode of Talk Python to Me.
Thank you to our sponsors.
Be sure to check out what they're offering.
It really helps support the show.
Take some stress out of your life.
Get notified immediately about errors and performance issues in your web
or mobile applications with Sentry.
Just visit talkpython.fm/sentry and get started for free.
And be sure to use the promo code talkpython, all one word.
Want to level up your Python?
We have one of the largest catalogs of Python video courses over at Talk Python.
Our content ranges from true beginners to deeply advanced
topics like memory and async.
And best of all, there's not a subscription in sight.
Check it out for yourself at training.talkpython.fm.
Be sure to subscribe to the show.
Open your favorite podcast app and search for Python.
We should be right at the top.
You can also find the iTunes feed at /iTunes, the Google Play feed at /play,
and the direct RSS feed at /rss on talkpython.fm.
We're live streaming most of our recordings these days.
If you want to be part of the show and have your comments featured on the air,
be sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel at talkpython.fm/youtube.
This is your host, Michael Kennedy.
Thanks so much for listening.
I really appreciate it.
Now get out there and write some Python code.
[MUSIC]
[END]
[MUSIC PLAYING]